Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. I think this is a Republican caller
explaining why educated Republicans are abandoning
the Republican Party.
Let's listen.
Speaker 8: You know, it's easy to see why
educated people are abandoning the Republican
Party in droves.
Speaker 1: And by the way, this is not Jimmy
from Philly.
I know the accent is similar.
This is not Jimmy from Philly.
Speaker 8: David doesn't take a genius to
figure out.
That.
When John Kennedy.
Asked Daisy, what are problems with voter
suppression?
He's just assuming that everybody is as stupid
as he is, right?
He doesn't realize that smart people are stupid
and that he's a stupid person and so.
Right.
Stupid people get called smart people stupid.
And expect them to hang around in their glove,
OK, stupid, right?
Smart people are sick of being called stupid
by Republicans, so obviously they're not going
to stay in the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: Wow, OK, I think I get it maybe,
but what is true is that educated voters are
leaving the Republican Party to a greater
degree.
OK, good.
I think we've sorted something out.
Maybe, but maybe not.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about West Virginia giving hundred
dollar savings bonds to young people who get
vaccinated.
A Florida McDonald's is now paying people
50 dollars just to show up for an interview.
Why?
We will discuss it.
And a man has been charged with infecting
22 people with covid after going to the gym
and work with active symptoms, not in the
United States.
Could this happen in the U.S.?
We will discuss that and much more and preview
tonight's live stream of Joe Biden's speech
on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom or a patron at Patreon
dot com The David Pakman Show.
We have the beautiful coupon code secret coupon
code on our website for membership discounts.
Immoral 21.
All one word, all lowercase, immoral.
Twenty one sign up.
I will see you on the bonus show and then
hopefully tonight for the live stream as well.